la réforme à 65 ans des retraites voté
pour ou contre moi je pense non une
réforme des retraites c'est pas comme ça
non mais c'est pas possible c'est pour
ça que les gens venaient jouer les
simples ma question pour ou contre moi
je suis contre j'ai le droit de vous
dire je suis content 60 ans et bien sûr
moi je suis comme est basique pour plus
ou moins non non moi
j'ai moi non mais juste un truc parce
qu'il
ya des
centaines rosso est dangereuse pourquoi
c'est une folie parce que parce qu'elle
dit n'importe quoi elle est hystérique
moi j'ai les reçus en l'a reçue elle est
à côté de moi et c'était la folie dans
ses propos dans tout son comportement sa
contentement attend c est quand on est
sortis moi je raconte toujours tout en
une franchise parce que j'en ai ren elle
est sortie je voulais juste lui dire
c'est intéressant ce que vous avez dit
mais vous l'avez mal dit rien comme ça
m'a dit mais ils disent que je veux
d'une agressivité cette fille mais ça va
pas l'intrus qui va pas dans sa vie
d'abord il ya plusieurs catégories de
personnes ce qu'on avait fait doux
nom j'ai du mal et qu'on politique pour
ça je pose des questions singe c'est
vous commencez votre tour elle a terminé
au langage de dourdan
d'une réforme des retraites on va
l'assemblée nationale ont dit oui non
mais c'est pas comme ça fonctionne telle
attitude pendant plusieurs semaines mais
pas si vous voulez une réponse binaire
nous sommes dans une époque maintenant
où on a tendance à se transformer en
patates de canapés ce livre on reste en
crèche oui c'est pas mal
et mes passions de temps en temps soyez
pas une patate de canapés matelas
donc ils sont là s'est passé soient en
retrait sur le canapé avec la
télécommande on muscle la télécommande
mais aux muscles plus son retour veineux
regardez regardez cette arrivée c'est
arrivé
awana bon bond à l'écran lé pa amb
ouvriers
oui c'est une très belle femme et je
n'avais pas envie qu'elle vienne au bout
l assemblée et le droit de le dire à
huit questions en boubou à l'assemblée -
fait mal et comme puisse avoir un
manneken pis athènes qui vous pis pour
vous servir à boire il ya comment tu
pouvais faire ça donc là je pense
vraiment que j'ai dû gagner des points
ah oui eh bien nous allons le vérifier
tout de suite auprès de jessica alors
quand je voyais les macaigne machin je
trouve ça pas très drôle je vous rassure
c'est de l'eau à
[Musique]
elle a un goût bizarre c'est au caire
oui dites moi l'on vous mettez sur table
oui c'est long terme c'est de l'eau de
l'eau du robinet mais voilà c'est bien
ce que je pensais c'est pas de l'eau
minérale alors là j'hallucine on me l'a
jamais fait c'est la sas et la tromperie
sur la marchandise à ça moi j'ai cru à
mon donné que je buvais de l'eau
minérale en bouteille que ça ne l'est
pas non ça par contre c'est interdit un
jeu de simulation de chat regardez les
images c'est un jeu en fait on est un
petit chaton un petit chaton orange et
on doit faire de chat c'est à dire qu'on
doit chercher à manger chasser des
oiseaux boire et quand on voit un canapé
dans qu'est ce qu'on fait quand on a un
challenge et déchire dans tous les sens
on peut on voit des humains on peut
demander des câlins comme ça plus
d'équipés nous casse et hop on s'en va
on est un vrai chat avec sa personnalité
bien caché dans ta tendresse
j'ai montré mes pinceaux le nez
[Musique]
de piscine
ap
on reparle de la coupe du monde au qatar
puisque la presse anglaise s'est penché
sur la loi là-bas au qatar et on
découvre que et bien les relations
sexuelles seront interdites hors mariage
c'est à dire pour les personnes qui ne
sont pas mariés et la fifa prévient
d'ores et déjà qu'il n'y aura pas
d'exception hors mariage est homosexuel
oui ça on le savait déjà mais en mariage
je reviens le défaut mais ils disent ils
ont précisé qu'il n'y aurait aucune
exception pendant toute la durée du
qatar et donc ceux qui viennent et
qu'ils sont étrangers et qui sont sur
place s'ils ont une relation sexuelles
extraconjugales ça vous une relation
homosexuelle c'est sept ans de prison
avec son pelage bleus et ses dents
acérées ce monstre tiré d'un jeu vidéo
inquiète départ en car depuis plusieurs
semaines la peluche guillou guide est
sorti des écrans pour s'inviter dans les
cours de récréation les goûters
d'anniversaire et autres produits
dérivés un phénomène qui créent de
l'anxiété et fait faire des cauchemars à
de nombreux enfants à en croire les
témoignages publiés en ligne selon les
spécialistes mieux vous en parler avec
eux si vos enfants ont déjà croisé la
route de guy roux dit
cette journée est une évidence au regard
des cinq dernières années truffaut
lameer qui se trouve comme ça oui c'est
dommage on va couper le courant
vous avez vu grandir a beaucoup m mais
qu'est ce que c'est elle est en tester
cette maison quoi
mûrir s'épanouir heureux et amoureux
non mais c'est une blague
on admire c'est
ça qu'on veut dire campagne contre on a
on a des messages de l'au delà oui et de
nos défunts d'accord il faut être très
attentif on va regarder on y aille à des
fantômes sur le plateau vous sentez vous
voyez pas ça va bien
[Rires]
voilà alors je vais pas le faire mais
nous on a essayé hop ça donne ça mais
c'est vachement dur quand même hein